students in high school there's this
feeling of Suffocation of everyone
trying to tell you you have to be the
absolute best
students truly believe that their class
Rank and where they go to college is
going to determine everything 4.0 isn't
enough anymore which is funny because
that used to be perfect but now it's all
about being better than perfect
I'm on here
writing the musical ranked we wanted to
amplify everything our students were
saying to us there's a huge pressure to
keep up GPA while balancing drama and
being on a sports team and the National
Honor Society at a school like Granite
Bay everyone knows where everyone is
rankwise technology has made it so
prevalent kids are oftentimes finding
themselves very miserable
[Music]
this tightness in my chest most parents
don't know I think this show started
conversations we had schools all over
the country reaching out to us wanting
to license and perform the show from
California to West Virginia to New York
saying hey these are our kids stories
too and how can we work with you to tell
that but then
school will be closed in response to the
covid-19 virus for a lot of kids theater
is where they find the place where they
belong can't do theater very well with a
mask on your face and then we realized
there was no reason ranked couldn't be
adapted online the Arts is our glue
during this pandemic
for our communities education is your
key to success
College represents a way to raise their
economic State happy ending
have a cost opportunities are not evenly
given out in this world
our students are growing up where
they're experiencing racism oppression
it's scary to see how the world really
is
[Music]
I can't let the pressure stop me I still
have to live my dreams
theater it gives me hope
I think this show is a bit of a wake-up
call
foreign